[Music]
well good afternoon thanks for joining
us at this session and and taking some
time out of this awesome conference so
my name is Randy Dyer I've been with
l.l.bean for 35 years and during that
time I've really been privileged to have
worked on our front-end systems in the
architecture and design of those systems
including a looming comm and our call
center systems hi there I'm Chris
Cummings I have been working in the
retail industry for many years and in
online retail direct-to-consumer
commerce for the last couple decades I
about 5 years ago I started a company
named fearless Technology Group we're a
consulting firm focused on helping
customers modernize their technology
architectures and we've been working
with l.l.bean since the start of the
modernization journey that we're going
to share with you here today I just want
to say thank you for coming out here to
hear us we're the last session of the
day I know we're between you and happy
hour and I know those seats are really
comfortable so hopefully you guys will
be somewhat interesting and keep you
awake here but thank you so we're going
to tell you a little bit about our
modernization journey we're going to
talk some about the evolution of
l.l.bean just so you can kinda see where
we're coming from here we're going to
talk about our case for a change and
then our vision for the future and then
we're going to talk about how we're
actually realizing that vision we'll
talk about some of the lessons we've
learned along the way and then we'll
talk a little bit about the journey
forward from here so if you don't know
Ella beam L beam is a company that sells
apparel and equipment for well either
casual wear or outdoors you might have
seen our boots or or have a pair of our
boots and our catalogues have been
around in the mail for a long time Ella
beam is a family-owned company
it's been in business since 1912 where
we started out as a catalog company LL
Bean is passionate about getting people
into the outdoors and our brand strategy
is really about providing products and
experiences that are made for the shared
joy of the outdoors recently we just
launched our be an outsider campaign you
might have seen that and that's really
about targeting getting families outside
and family is whatever you consider your
family would be your kids your pets or
whatever and then also we've extended
that you may have seen a little bit of
that into the workplace with our be an
outsider at work when we partnered with
industrious to deliver some outside work
spaces in around different cities so
like I mentioned l.l.bean started out as
a catalog company back in 1912 and
catalog is what really drove our
business for the first part of the 20th
century in 1996 we launched our
e-commerce website it was pretty early
on in that era and today our e-commerce
website actually accounts for more than
two-thirds of our revenue other than the
catalog up until the early 2000s we
really had just one retail store located
in Freeport Maine where the company
headquarters are and into early 2000s or
so we started to expand our retail
presence a bit and today we've got over
50 stores a you know around the country
and kiosks and and some other mobile
stores as well
part of the as we as we kind of went
through the change on on how we were
in delivering capabilities to our
customers and doing business each
Channel
sort of kind of grew up on its own so we
had systems to really support that
Direct Marketing and catalog and you
know phone order entries and those kinds
of things when we launched the website
we had a website that had a lot of the
capabilities for taking orders over the
web and then store sales part of the
issue is is that as times gone on and
customers have started experiencing us
across these different channels their
interactions are changing as well they
want to do things with and interact with
alibiing in all of those different
channels and they want to do it
seamlessly and part of the problem was
is that our systems had really kind of
reached a point where they just couldn't
support those evolving customer needs
okay we're gonna get to the what we did
here soon but one thing first is just
highlight that this is not a unique to
LL Bean trend it's not even a unique to
retail trend there are customers across
all kinds of verticals are changing
their behavior they they have different
expectations of brands and there's all
kinds of metrics out there in the
industry to reference step we pulled
three of them up here to share first one
Harvard Business Review says seventy
three percent of consumers now use
multiple channels when making a purchase
from a brand and eighty-seven percent of
the customer survey think that brands
need to invest more in making those
experiences across channels more
consistent so they're clearly saying
something to the brand's these days that
they're not happy the experiences are
not consistent they're they want the
same company no matter whether they're
interacting with them on a web channel
on their phone in the store and they
don't want to start a transaction in one
channel and then you know start from
scratch and enough
so expectations have been raised for the
brand's investment is required but the
good news is that there is ROI available
last metric is 30% higher lifetime value
for customers interacting through
multiple channels versus those who only
engage through a single channel and and
though the bar has been raised the
brands are stepping up they need to step
up and meet this challenge and and
frankly the way we've all been building
systems for the last two decades is no
longer good enough to meet that
challenge something clearly has to
change so about three years ago we were
approached and asked if we could look at
how we can simplify the interactions
with our customers so one of the things
that we did is just took a step back and
and looked at all of those different
interactions and you know saw that
things like you know a customer might
come into a store with an item that they
purchased online and they want to return
it and they want to replace it with an
with another item that maybe doesn't
exist in the store so that order is
going to then be placed in the store and
you know shipped from the online channel
as an example so in looking at all of
those different interactions we started
to then step back and say what are the
inhibitors what's kind of keeping us
from delivering those those cleaner
customer experiences as I mentioned
earlier our systems were a core part of
some of those barriers not that they
didn't have great capabilities because
in their own channels and in their own
right they do but they just weren't
designed to work with each other for
these these new kind of interactions so
we step back and and looked at our
architecture application architecture to
really understand what was going on and
some of the things what we found are you
know somewhat obvious the applications
were siloed but what that means is it
made it difficult for us to provide sort
of a common customer experience there
those applications were monolithic some
of them are
getting long in the tooth some of them
have been in place for twenty years or
so they were implemented back in the
days when we did monolithic systems and
tightly coupled and all of that kind of
thing so ultimately that just makes
those applications costly and
challenging to change a small change in
one of these applications requires that
we go through and do all kinds of
regression testing to make sure that we
haven't broken things unintentionally
and that's manually intensive all of
these applications are delivered through
on premise infrastructure and not that
that's a bad thing but in some ways it's
it's limiting we don't have a lot of
flexibility or ability to deliver new
new infrastructure and capabilities
rapidly and then you know with a with a
seasonal business like ours as you might
imagine during the holidays we get
really busy a lot of the rest of the
year we're you know much less busy but
we have to plan for that capacity all
year long so we took a step back and try
to come up with or understand what we
needed to change in order to solve some
of these issues we came up with what we
described what we called our
omni-channel architecture in this
architecture really was designed to meet
the goals of supporting these customer
consistent customer experiences we also
needed to improve our agility and our
speed to market getting new capabilities
out there and we needed it to be built
on a modern architecture I've been
around this merio ground enough times
that this would probably be about the
third time that we've reimagined and
Riaan visioned these applications to
serve our customers and so we're we're
just sort of planning for that next
cycle to see you know make sure it can
kind of you know can live that that
lifecycle so the the vision that we
created this is a what we found that we
needed to do is we had a we had sort of
envisioned a lot of different
capabilities around micro services and
you know cloud platforms and all of this
kind of thing but when you want to sell
that to an executive you had got to
simplify it and so what we did is
created sort of this one-page vision
document that described what it is that
we wanted to do and I'm not going to go
into a lot of details on this but what
we the the idea here was that this isn't
this isn't sort of the system design
this is really a tool just for
communicating with those executives and
what we found is that having something
like this was really important because
every time we went into a meeting with
those executives you know we you know
they're busy they got a lot on their
minds and we had to kind of refresh them
on you know what is we're talking about
why are we talking about it that kind of
thing and so having something like this
was really valuable for doing that it
was also eye-opening in that you know
the obviously executives sort of know
what we do is a business but when you
start to put all of the pieces kind of
in front of them then it's it starts to
open their eyes up a little bit about
just you know all of the the complexity
that's there when you do something like
this one of the things you want to do is
use a little bit of artistic license and
so for example just as you look at the
picture you can see that the systems on
the bottom the enterprise applications
you know don't really compare and scale
to what's on the top those are obviously
large important critical applications
but they're not the focus of what we're
targeting so you know they're just kind
of a
you know a little less in scale there so
anyway the point of this is create a
vision make it simple
put it on one page what we found after
doing this as well is that other teams
started using this document in their
presentations and in their selling of
what they wanted to do so that they so
they could sort of latch on to the
success that we're having here with with
our momentum so I just kind of boiled
down that document a little bit so that
we could talk a little bit more about
how Google Cloud fits into all of this
so at the top of the diagram we had our
customer we have our customer
interaction applications and that could
be our point-of-sale system or our
customer facing website our mobile web
custom Store applications contacts and
our etc all of those applications or in
our vision and what we're working toward
is that those applications share
capabilities through shared services
which are exposed as api's and those
shared servers could either be
custom-built they could be purchased or
they could be legacy like in the case of
our commerce system today we've we've
actually been working on several parts
of this we have several pieces into in
production today so as an example our
customer facing website the UI layer of
our customer facing website many of the
pages that you see if you go to a
website today are actually delivered you
know with this with this architecture
some core services like purchase history
inventory availability service are
delivered as
services today and we are in the process
of implementing a promotion service that
we actually purchased as we speak all of
this is tied together through an API
gateway we are using Apogee as our at
the API gateway today we've actually
been using Apogee for probably three
plus years at this point so we actually
had a pretty good base of api's already
in Apogee and then so just to to so
where does where does Google Cloud fit
into this that customer facing UI like I
mentioned runs on TCP and gke those
custom services also run in gke and that
purchase service will run in gke we've
got some on Prem services that are that
are not in gke they're really part of
our legacy commerce application but we
are leveraging those and we've laid
layered an API layer on top of that ok
so you've seen where we started at
l.l.bean and you've seen where we're
trying to go how we're trying to realize
this vision and what it looks like so
how did we come to use Google cloud
platform let's talk about that it's
Google Conference and we chose GCP about
a year and a half ago we didn't really
start there though with the first thing
we embraced pretty strongly on this
journey to realize the vision was
kubernetes and really first and foremost
containers but then as we we looked for
a place to operate those containers
deploy run them we we embraced
kubernetes and we went after the
containers early because we just saw the
benefits the immutability of those
environments the ability to spin up
environments rapidly during the dev
cycle scale horizontally very easily if
the apps designed for it was just very
compelling so we embraced containers
kubernetes that led us a bit naturally
to Google cloud platform at that time
there was really not
the game in town from the big providers
they were starting to talk about
kubernetes they weren't embracing it
that has changed in a big way everybody
is scrambling to catch up but Google
still pretty much the leader here but
that wasn't the only thing kubernetes is
a great example of Google's open source
commitment and we're benefiting from
that with a number of other applications
that we use and and we just really liked
that open source commitment we like
their whole approach to it we didn't see
quite the same stance with the other
providers security architecture there
were some things about Google's security
architecture that we thought were very
appropriate for a cloud native
environment that zero trust approach was
different than traditional on-premise
approaches that were being used at the
time we encountered it but we could see
the power we embraced it and we've kind
of blended what Google brings to the
table there along with some security
capabilities that are there with
container containerized apps there's
some things you can do that are kind of
you a new and unique in some ways and
then we've blended a few on-premise
measures into the mix for a pretty
healthy blend on the security front a
few other things to hit quickly here
dynamic scale Randy mentioned the
seasonality that's a big win for a
retailer not not surprising cloud native
and you brings the ability to position
teams to innovate a lot of that's by the
speed at which they can move to market
the speed of which they can try new
technologies we we really felt like we
had the tools necessary with Google in
that area and then finally being a
retailer with digital marketing there's
a key business relationship with
l.l.bean and Google that we felt was an
advantage and with cloud native in
general with some things with Google and
particularly we like the pricing model
so what does our deployment look like on
on GCP well I'm gonna go yet more simple
here and just highlight three major
components that make up the core of what
we are doing Google cloud native GCP gke
is obviously a key part of that but over
the top of that we've laid
Marco services architecture down and we
really embraced micro-services earliest
in the game here and we we really
embraced the principles behind
micro-services the domain driven design
concepts that are there the the
separation of concerns the the loosely
coupled applications bounded context
language having meaning with those cont
within those contexts and we we also
embraced the idea that teams could align
with application domains business
domains and when you mix all that into a
micro services environment deployed the
right way it really allows you to move
all the pieces forward at their own pace
really really change the game for
l.l.bean at the time micro services word
is widely adopted outside of the big
internet companies it's become much more
industry standard now I'm much more
accepted also here DevOps pipeline is a
key part of the puzzle continuous
integration and delivery that's how
everything gets built tested stress
tested vulnerability scanned deployed
monitored maintained all of that there's
a strong pipeline here that is is a key
part of everything that goes out onto
the platform and a key part of what we
consider our platform so this looks
really simple is it really that simple
no it's really not that simple there
there's actually a lot more going on
then that simple picture shows there is
a healthy mix of things that Google
provides as a service but there's also a
bunch of stuff that we've brought to the
table and and really the point of this
slide is not to talk about each one of
these things but to highlight that the
cloud native approach we chose allows us
a lot of flexibility to mix the bits and
pieces together that we feel are right
for a given job and you know for
examples our GCP the backbone GCP itself
compute engine kubernetes engine things
like pups up for event messaging cloud
spanner as a service relational database
that we use for inventory availability
and some other things all great stuff we
get as managed services but on the stuff
we've rolled we
we have key dev components def pipeline
stuff github Jenkins CI Nexus artifact
repository we use terraform for
infrastructure automation and then just
as an example MongoDB we chose to go
with [ __ ] for some reasons that were
very specific to our use case but we
were able to deploy that as a service
for our dev teams so from a dev team
standpoint the relational DB they've got
an option with spanner and with other
things but with a with a document store
DB they've got an option with [ __ ] and
they don't have to go build that
themselves they can use it so powerful
mix going with cloud native and and
putting the pieces out there to enable
the dev teams but how do we do all that
at LL Bean well one of the things that
we did early in the process is we
established what we call a platform
services team and this team has a
mission the mission is to maintain the
systems and processes necessary for a
gel and continuous software delivery and
furthermore to enable the dev teams to
embrace DevOps culture and practice so
these guys aren't the development team
these guys are the platform team who
maintains the platform stewards it
forward takes care of security concerns
manages and maintains that devops
pipeline and a myriad of other things
they collaborate heavily with the dev
teams our our dev teams build software
applications using all this and they
deploy them just a few practice areas to
highlight and and their mantra and you
know if those of you who have read the
continuous delivery book and the DevOps
handbook you see some things that
probably look familiar here but automate
everything if you're doing micro
services at scale if you're going cloud
native you can't really have manual
steps and all this if you're gonna be
efficient just doesn't work but they do
things like infrastructure automation
scripting this stuff to create the
systems and configs that are necessary
letting teams spin up environments
really quickly and easily everything to
do with continuous delivery is in their
domain and then site reliability
engineering you know we want to push out
fast we also want to be stable get
immediate feedback react
to that and and make sure we've got
healthy systems go forward so big lesson
learned we'll share a few more lessons
learned here in a few slides but
strongly recommend you consider if
you've got some magnitude in your
environment a platform services team to
help you forward great so before I move
on I'd one thing I wanted to add word to
what Chris was just saying is on that
list which I won't flip back to but on
that list you might have saw a cloud
spanner on there for example and cloud
spanner in some ways might be a bit
overkill for what we're using it for
today we've got some other use cases
where it'll be more effective but one of
the things that about that is that I
want my teams to be focused on the
customer and deliver delivering customer
value I don't want my team's to have to
become technology experts and learn how
to do things like stand-up database
environments that a high of Aliev
ailable and all of that kind of stuff
there are technology providers that can
do that much better than then we can and
much more efficiently than we can and
that's why we want to leverage that kind
of thing so just wanted to call that out
one of the things I'm going to talk
about is one of the examples at
applications that we delivered and I've
already mentioned it that's the Ella
Bean calmly stay UI layer of that
el-amin a common website and the reason
I want to talk about it is because I'm
going to talk a little bit about how
we've we've how this platform has really
given us some capabilities that we
didn't have before there so in order to
really explain this I got to talk a
little bit about the you know how our
current how our legacy website was was
built and architected we first
implemented it back in 1996 like I
mentioned it went on it went under when
a big technology change in about 2001
when we switched it over to the Webster
commerce platform and all based on Java
and
je and all of those you know kinds of
technologies the UI layer at the time
was was really part of that monolith
implemented in jsps and as time goes by
we you know the the site became more
dynamic we we started layering on lots
of JavaScript to make that make
everything you know dynamic and and
robust and then as new devices started
to become prominent then we added more
JavaScript to handle those kinds of
things so anyway it got to the point
where the that UI application was was
just very complex and fragile and
difficult to maintain and and all of
that so that was another thing so we
said we got to step back and figure out
a better way to do this so we came up
with what we called the sort of just
simply the front-end architecture and
what front-end architecture is is a
framework that we put together using
based primarily on react and other
open-source libraries all based in
nodejs
and this architecture allows us to
deliver customer facing applications
that that will run on either desktop
mobile or tablets you know any of the
any form factors there and like I
mentioned we are using it to replace
that UI layer on Ella bean comm today
and we have plans to use it for other
capabilities as well like in our call
centers not only is it using react but
the architecture also defines how we use
react so it employs an atomic design
model that that really mandates that all
the all the components are loosely
coupled and independently independently
develop all developable and deployable
and obviously the supports response
of web design and accessibility
requirements out-of-the-box and we've
found that since we've implemented it's
it's actually been a pretty good
improvement in performance and gives us
some scalability and speed to market
with this and it just is a platform that
gives us the ability to support ongoing
experience optimization so I mentioned
that we we have gone to production with
many of the pages on our website under
this architecture and that deployment
obviously is on Google cloud platform or
in google kubernetes engine so what the
value of the platform brought to all of
this though is that other than the
scaling and things I mentioned is that
so a little case study here a few weeks
ago we implemented a new version of this
application that included capability
around the the category pages and
shortly after we were deployed we
started getting some alerts from the
monitoring that we had set up and those
alerts were telling us that kubernetes
was doing lots of pod restarts and so we
looked into and it was starting it was
doing the pod restarts because we had
seen that the memory had started memory
usage it started climbing pretty rapidly
and kubernetes we had set it up with
some thresholds it says when you get to
a certain point in memory usage restart
yourself so that everything stays clean
and running and so that's what it was
doing and so because it was doing that
customers never saw that we were having
an issue and you know never had any
downtime or anything like that I point
this out because if this were our legacy
website that doesn't have these
ability that doesn't have something like
kubernetes doing you know this kind of
management then it probably would have
keeled over and twitch its feet for a
while but that didn't happen in this
case the other part of the about this
like Chris mentioned we've got the CI CD
pipeline in place that allows us to do
rapid deployments and frequent
deployments so as part of the problem
resolution to all of this we were able
to get in analyze what was going on make
changes and get it into production
quickly turned out that the problem was
actually a little deeper than what we
thought so the first implementation
didn't didn't solve the problem but
because again the rapid ability to turn
things around we were able to get the
issue solved in about four hours on our
legacy site that probably would have
been at least a day in and overnight in
order to solve something like that and
likely very likely would have been an
outage to the website so that's just an
example of some of the capability and
advantage that we've seen on the
platform so far okay so I mentioned some
learnings we were going to share and we
we picked five things to raise up and
and highlight here in reality we are
practicing agile here so we were doing
iterations retros continuously learning
and trying to improve but when you step
back and you look at the big picture of
what we were doing v stood out and we
thought they would be worth sharing with
you a couple of them you've already
heard something about number one
established that vision for the future
you saw what the one for LL Bean looked
like yours will look different but it's
really important that you do that up
front and you do it in a way that
everyone in the organization who needs
to can embrace it
so the ite on-the-ground folks the
developers have to be able to understand
the IT management has to get on board
but those executives have to understand
at the right level what this is that
we're trying to do and the reason that's
important is because this is not a
project this is a journey so if you have
an organization of any magnitude that
you're trying to do this in it's going
to be a multi-year commitment and that
multi-year commitment is going to have
to have executive sponsorship it's gonna
have to have budget there's no way you
can get there without selling that this
is a journey worth taking and that
vision is in is critical to do that it's
okay to start with prototype projects
and such at the outset we did that but
really you can't think about it as a
project don't do that but do iterate you
can do this by iterating by bringing
business value along the way by learning
and changing course as you go but it's
gonna take time third one embrace DevOps
is what we summed it up as but what it
really means is to get the ROI out of a
big modernization effort you have to
recognize it's more than just the
technology it's the people and the
process you you won't get the benefit if
you keep trying to build software the
way you've always built it if you're not
willing to reorganize we're appropriate
to align teams with product domains
allow them some independence and
evolving those and deploying them let
them fail fast and recover it's it's a
different way of thinking for a lot of
companies and it's frankly way harder
than the technology here it's we we kind
of challenged pretty much everything
that ello bean was doing with software
development when we went when we went
after this but it's it's it's worth it's
worth doing fourth thing have already
talked about establish a platform
services team especially if you're going
cloud native especially if you have more
than a few development teams it will pay
off and then finally engage security at
the outset we we hear this all the time
right people are always telling us get
security onboard up front we did this
and in hindsight if we had waited six
months 12 months 18 months down the road
then tried to retrofit security in it
would not have been a good outcome it
would have been very costly and painful
it would have disrupted development
trucks and it's pretty likely it would
not have been as good an outcome as we
have now but we we did this up front and
the way we did that twofold one we
established an executive sponsorship
team a steering committee if you will at
LL Bean key business execs who had a
stake in what we were doing and the
right IT management resources the head
of security was on that committee and so
he was there at the outset as we started
talking about going to the cloud going
cloud native when we established a
platform team we added a security
architect to that team so that that
individual was there right up front and
it's it's paid off we we really had no
idea where the security path was going
to lead when we started and and we found
our way through and we continued to
evolve but we thought it to a good place
so just a few lessons there there are
probably hundreds or thousands of micro
lessons you come across as you do
something like this five that we thought
were worth mentioning to you great so
where are we going from here so we
mentioned we actually started this
effort a couple of years ago at the time
gke was pretty early in the market and I
don't remember exactly which version we
started on maybe one point for something
like that so we we had to do a lot of
work - you know secure things get things
interconnected the way they needed to be
with what we had at the time obviously
since then things like sto are coming on
board that can solve a lot of the
problems that we we had to kind of work
work around at the time so part of this
journey is to continually evolve that
platform as as new capabilities come in
as new as things change and to continue
to build out
that's that layer of services that that
you saw earlier so we've got
development in a way wait right now with
with some new capabilities that we'll be
rolling out probably at this well
actually complete development before our
peak season but we actually won't roll
them out until after just because but we
don't want to do that and then the other
thing that we are doing is as many of
the legacy systems that were that we're
replacing at this point like I mentioned
are fairly old some of them a very batch
oriented and so as we're going through
this we are connecting we're really
looking at these from more of an event
based approach and so part of the the
work that we're doing is starting to
leer some event processing capabilities
onto the platform and then the other
thing that we've that we've got going on
is as a direct marketer you as you might
expect we've got a lot of data a lot of
data about our customers and how they
interact with us and we use that data to
model and for for delivering catalogs
and emails and all of those kinds of
things so there's a lot of analysis that
that we do and up until this point we've
done that really with your traditional
enterprise data warehouse capabilities
and tools like SAS and and some of these
other things but again as things like
the you know targeted targeted ads and
all of that kind of thing just have
created more and more data that we need
to process and so we're just running out
of our current infrastructure just
running out of steam with doing that so
we've got some work underway where we
are pulling a lot of that data into the
Google cloud platform
and using tools like bigquery and cloud
yes sorry Dena flow I
with all these tools I can't keep track
of all of them but so that work is
underway and like Chris mentioned this
is that we've we've got a road map for
all of this work that we've created and
we expect to be continued on this road
map for at least the next few years as
we bring all of this together so we hope
we've given you some some some
information and some insights into our
journey and hopefully they can help you
so thank you and so before we leave I
just want to invite all of you to also
become an outsider enjoy the outdoors
and you can find us at you know those at
LM in comm we are here for questions if
anybody wants to ask questions we're
also here at the conference if you want
to if anybody's interested in in
chatting in more detail we're certainly
willing to do that so thank you I guess
if anybody has a question it'll actually
see a microphone so you could just shout
it and we're pretty close oh I see it
there it is up there
[Music]
hey guys thanks for the yeah in fact our
current website is on a commercial
product so to speak it's on Webster
commerce and so we absolutely did
consider that one of the things that we
in our current implementation our
website is is relatively rich in
capabilities and we wanted to keep that
in our current implementation we had to
do a lot of customization in order to
get there and that was just kind of a
model that we didn't really want to go
down at this point you know at this
point in time the other thing is you
know again we've we've got a pretty big
presence still in the call centers so we
get a lot of orders you know coming in
over the phone and so we really wanted
to be able to blend those channels
together and you know that was something
that we just didn't see really happening
well and sort of those products they're
really targeted either for you know
digital commerce or whatever I would
have one thing to that and that it's
just LL Bean is a pretty sophisticated
digital marketer in a lot of ways and I
think there was a desire to have some
best-of-breed capabilities in a number
of different areas versus kind of get
inside someone's platform and just live
within there and I don't I've seen those
in multiple places sometimes they've
they've worked well a lot of times you
know the dream doesn't come together by
getting this all from one vendor but
that was that was a play as well
so so I would say it's it was both we
you know see the original thoughts
around you know our customer base and
those kinds of things and oh by the way
we're not really servicing them very
well is something that our leadership
had recognized you know a while ago and
so so that's kind of how it started from
there we kind of took it and said all
right what are those what's what's sort
of the things that are that are holding
us back there and what do we need to do
so that's kind of when it kind of became
that blend of more you know business and
technology kinds of things our sponsor
really was when we when we started this
off was the senior vice president of
marketing and he was kind of our our
initial support from there though we we
quickly were able to get the support of
the CIO and the other the chief
marketing officer and you know all of
really the c-suite there so it was that
one pager honestly was that one page
that kind of brought everybody together
it was probably kind of mind-boggling to
me that that did what it did but it was
worth about a billion words in this case
nothing else happy hour all right thanks
everybody thank you
[Music]